en 2020 on aurait censé près de 75 000
collisions sur les routes du pays ça ça
en fait des véhicules à réparer mais
depuis la pandémie certaines pièces de
voitures nous arrivent au compte-goutte
ça c'est à cause des problèmes à bien
des consommateurs
[Musique]
l'hiver dernier a été particulièrement
difficile sur les routes du Québec
joël vendry a eu un accident avec sa
Mazda CX-5 et Marie-Ève Pelletier
également avec sa Mazda CX9 quand la
remorqueuse le sortie de là j'ai vu le
devant arraché donc la radiateur était
endommagé
on a tout le côté de l'aile aussi on
parle d'un 14000 dollars de dommages sur
le camion
en raison de ces brimageurs les deux
voitures sont immobilisées dans la cour
des carrossiers pour une durée
indéterminée
[Musique]
mer de quatre enfants Marie-Eve ne peut
pas se passer d'une voiture
elle est plus que avec les quatre
enfants qui sont très actifs je pourrais
vous montrer mon calendrier madame il
faudrait que les casses soient plus
grandes que marquer les choses de chacun
quelques jours après l'accident une
autre tuile tombe sur la tête de
Marie-Ève l'assurant m'appelle pour me
dire écoutez madame on a appelé partout
pour les pièces de véhicules il y en a
une majeure qui est
backcorder savent pas quand ils vont
pouvoir mettre la main dessus même
constat pour une pièce essentielle à la
réparation de la voiture de Joël ça peut
prendre jusqu'à six mois un an donc vous
demandez une voiture de location des
personnes que je connais ont déjà eu des
accidents à faire puis ce sont faites
prête à lui que je me suis dit ça vient
avec
est assuré avec la SSQ assurance et
Marie-Eve Pelletier avec Desjardins
assurances
sans même se connaître elle constate les
mêmes lacunes dans leur contrat
d'assurance respectifs je vous appelle
pour dire qu'on a un maximum de location
qui est fourni qui est dans votre
contrat pardon j'avais jamais entendu
parler de ça jamais il a été mention
d'un montant maximal de location lors
d'une accident son contrat prévoit un
montant maximal de 3000 dollars cela
représente environ deux mois de location
c'est à vous de débourser les frais je
me suis mis à pleurer comme un bébé au
téléphone en disant que ça avait je peux
pas me permettre ça
de location au maximum Marie-Eve choisit
la voiture la moins chère possible donc
la plus petite avance
67 jours de location plus tard elle doit
aujourd'hui payer de sa poche c'est 1000
pièces par mois plus ma voiture
plus mes ascendants plus
j'ai quatre enfants
le coût de la vie là ça coûte cher mais
j'ai certainement pas mis le pied à
mettre nulle part par mois
Joël vendrit ignorer aussi que son
contrat prévoyait seulement
2250 dollars pour 28 jours de location
de voiture si j'avais su qu'il y avait
un montant maximal pour un véhicule de
location je leur ai fait augmenter on en
prend des assurances justement pour que
ça arrive des situations comme celle-là
qu'on soit pas mal pris là je me
retrouve mal pris pareil on paye toute
notre vie pour des assurances finalement
de se faire lâcher comme ça quand on a
une problématique c'est quand même ça se
peut pas j'ai tout de suite été voir le
contrat de comprendre c'est quoi cette
clause là
cette clause c'est l'avenant frais de
déplacement ou FAQ 20 le montant maximal
de cet avenant qui est présent dans la
majorité des contrats d'assurance
automobile au Québec est différent d'une
entreprise à l'autre il varie entre 2000
et 5000 dollars
une fois leur fond épuisé les deux
accidentés tentent d'obtenir de leur
carrossier respectifs une voiture de
service familièrement appelée voiture de
courtoisie c'était juste non
malheureusement tant que j'ai pas les
pièces moi je peux pas vous pointer un
véhicule de courtoisie Lucie c'est un
peu comme les assurances de Madame c'est
comme ça c'est tout est-ce qu'il y a une
obligation pour le carrossier de prêter
une voiture de courtoisie à l'assurer
légalement non dans les empreintes
commerciales qui prévalent oui
Michel Bourbourg représente plus de 350
carrossiers sur les milles du Québec
selon lui il faut revoir l'entente
commerciale entre les assureurs et les
carrossiers négocier dans les années 80
l'entente était bonne il y a 20 ans
aujourd'hui est obsolète s'applique plus
mais l'assureur
de maintenir cette alliance là qui est à
son avantage parce que le client paye un
fois q20 mais lui il fournit pas le
véhicule c'est dans l'entendre
commercial
selon cette entente les carrossiers
reçoivent 25 dollars par jour des
compagnies d'assurance pour la voiture
de service
cependant ce montant est versé seulement
à partir du moment où la réparation
commence les carrossiers refusent donc
de fournir un véhicule pendant la longue
attente des pièces c'est parce que
le véhicule la flotte de véhicule les
frais d'opération d'entretien et de les
pneus l'essence carrossier prête un
véhicule de courtoisie à un client qui
se promène avec pendant des semaines des
mois mais il est pas rémunéré pour ça
puisque l'assureur donne aux carrossier
c'est pas toujours la valeur réelle d'un
véhicule de location aussi donc ce que
vous demandez aux assureurs c'est
d'assumer 100% de la facture l'entièreté
de la facture liée du véhicule le
remplacement on a pu accès aux pièces
comme avant ça crée des insatisfactions
pour le consommateur qui sont qui sont
inacceptables on a vu de la
problématique prendre une ampleur
importante à partir de février mars
Patrice Longchamp et le directeur
principal de l'indemnisation chez bénéva
une entreprise créée par la fusion entre
la SSQ assurance et la capitale depuis
mai dernier bénévat a bonifié son offre
aux assurés ce qu'on a fait chez bénéva
autant du côté de l'assureur SSQ
assurance que de l'assureur la capitale
on a ajouté des jours au montant maximum
qui était permis donc on a ajouté un 14
jours additionnels de location avec un
montant maximal de 37 valeur et demi par
jour de location ça c'est pour la SSQ
oui Desjardins assurances à Quentin elle
refusait nous recevoir mais par courriel
est l'affirme avoir ajusté ces contrats
en doublant le montant maximal qui est
passé de 1500 à 3000 dollars
pour Joël et Marie-Ève les efforts des
assureurs ne sont pas suffisants
c'est toujours nous que s'adaptons
souvent les consommateurs je trouve mais
je souhaite que eux s'adapte pour
vraiment les rende aux gens parce que
c'est une entreprise qui doit venir en
aide les assurances ta dernière chance
c'est ton toit va avoir un véhicule
d'occasion finalement il fallu que je
m'achète un troisième véhicule là on
sera masser qu'on avait des paiements
pour notre camion on a deux invicule
puis là il y avait ceux pour le
troisième véhicule pendant que mon
camion est en réparation enfin je payais
pour ces frais là mais j'avais pas mon
auto finalement joël a pu récupérer sa
voiture réparer deux mois après son
accident mais elle a dû assumer une
perte monétaire lors de la revendue
véhicule d'occasion pas que le véhicule
nous a coûté 5000 au total puis quand on
leur vendu on était récupéré comme un
3002 sur le sur le 5000 de son côté
Marie-Ève est toujours dans
l'incertitude j'ai pas aucune date on le
sait pas du tout du tout du tout et si
la pièce n'arrive pas à bien deux mois
mais ça n'arrive pas avant deux ans
madame c'est encore pire je suis
quelqu'un qui qui s'arrange toujours de
ça il y a toujours une solution mais là
j'en ai plus j'en ai plus
de la chance son concessionnaires il y
en a prêté un véhicule gratuitement un
beau geste et vous le savez vous ce que
prévoit votre contrat d'assurance